News hello everyone hello so we're gonna
get into a delicious little room and a
lobby I never say whether I want to be
Jason or a counselor because I like to
be surprised if you've never seen if
you've never seen this game it's
fantastic it's basically one person
plays Jason and I think five people play
counselors and if you're a counselor you
have to escape there's a bunch of
different stuff you can do if you're
Jason all you have to do is kill
everybody it's that easy it's that easy
[Music]
so yes hello MC Gary 4vp pookie man wait
is that Pookie man I went to college
with Pookie man good lord
hey tunnel sickness 22 I hope it's not
total Oh a lot of people are talking a
lot of people are talking oh my goodness
you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna do
a thing where I'm you everyone let's see
here I'll click on their thing yeah not
that I don't like these people but I
just I don't care what they have to say
it doesn't matter to me you know it
don't matter I don't like to talk to
people when I play games online I don't
even know in a microphone it's something
I don't enjoy I'm ready to go man let's
go let's make it happen where the Conan
gurgaon Conan is actually not feeling
well Conan sick I know I make a lot of
excuses for Conan but this week he is
actually ill which isn't great
oh it's college Pookie man well well
well hello Steven yes burski
yes we played it I plead playing this on
my own stream which is super fun we
played it over the weekend on Sunday I
stream on Sunday nights and there's a
part in this game where to escape you
can
get some gasoline you can get a battery
you get the car keys you start the car
you can drive off and two people drove
off and I was like hey and I was very
mind I was like hey hey Jason was
chasing me I was like hey guys guys guys
and they stopped and they backed up and
they killed me by running me over and
then they drove away so it was it was a
little bit of a how do you say
major bummer yes that's exactly happened
so uh yeah yeah yeah yeah
hey Reverend nine hundred we are at
Warner Brothers we're in our digital
studio the Warner Brothers lot shameless
right outside that door actually they're
giving a bunch of shameless extras not
extra super shameless but extras for the
show shameless costumes which is lares
they're just like I'm this truck just
handing people right outside our office
oh yeah look at this oh it's so bloody
send the kids out of the room send the
kids out of the room
what up great Dylan dr. delirious what's
a dick move oh yeah give me getting hit
by car that was it major dick move
exactly Conan sitting right here guys
this is what he looks like in real life
they got the eyes right his big lifeless
black eyes if you were at Comic Con with
us last year these are actually we put
VR headsets in here and there he goes
there's behind the scenes of the Conan
head and so you could wear this and and
see conan vr which is pretty dope so yes
King Mamba I love Conan too especially
because he pays me money
not a lot of money all right guys here
we go I think I'm a counselor I'm super
nervous this game frightens me I'm not
gonna lie oh I love that guy that's the
Jason with the spear though he sucks
all right here we go man I'm always this
dude this guy sucks
all right normally I just try to hide
this time I might try to uh I might try
to help man the TV's so dark I gotta
make it more bright I can't see where
I'm going you guys oh what's gonna
happen ah so no guys I'm nervous
it's so dark but I can't spare the time
what's up bro oh come on
also I suck at this game everybody this
guy's just like dude close the door I'll
kill you
fortified let's open a window you know
this case we have to jump out
- I'll take the frying pan for sure all
right
some kombucha oh man you know I should
get Jordan in here that would be fun who
can we call the cops you need to listen
to me
Jason Voorhees just returned geez we're
gonna be just staring into the camera
I'm gonna make this brighter I can't see
anything
oh dude this is great the cops are
already coming we only got really got
five minutes here we go we just got to
hide he's a good idea or a bad idea to
hide there's Thunder happening outside
your flight MC Gary are you want a plane
this game is ridiculous I agree Serpico
jaesi can't still see me if I'm hiding
come out of the closet let's see that
all my life
hello - OH - for this game is horrifying
view lis head
don't hide here why not borrow Jason see
here's the thing I'm doing oh look at
this at a hole I'm doing reverse
psychology because if I were Jason right
and somebody used the phone box I would
think that immediately they ran away
from the phone box I wouldn't think that
they're actually hiding next to the
phone box like a stupid idiot like I am
alright the circle outline thing would
he does a teleport ability uh-oh
we only gotta hide for 3:26 though guys
we'll see Johnny tau
what up cream shooter a big cream in the
house whose camera is a thing spatulate
idli screened it last night it was
hilarious people liked it and I think
it's either gonna be on the show tonight
or tomorrow night I believe the new
clues gamer very exciting privilege
white guy I think I'm safe that's true
you would think so but a lot of white
guys died in these movies I agree jump
scare I'm trying to set it up
sup Samuel Ortiz the second field builds
up Jason is a folk tale legend told by
the locals comes off pretty corny but
then it's a Friday 13th movie
well the first one guys I'm sorry
spoiler alert for a movie that came out
in the 70s the first one Jason is
actually not in that that's the big
thing is everybody thinks it's Jason
did you guys hear uh oh no oh oh he's
getting killed he's getting killed real
hard over there oh my god oh my god here
he comes don't hide in here dude
[Music]
am i dead or what I'm hoping that bloody
dudes gonna draw him away from me Oh Oh
God
sorry Mike ooh ooh oh lordy Oh a little
fireworks action whoo that was close
that was close
hey Duffy hello England Koda plays me
sometimes oh uh
that guy's terrified face was in many
different ways terrifying it was
horrifying that's for sure
I hope the guy playing Jason isn't
watching the stream because that would
really suck whoa creature has been
following me for two years
hey creep shooter aah I'm gonna get to
your new stream Jason uses his senses he
could still come after you I don't know
man when I was Jason I mean grand I was
a dumb Jason you know especially I don't
know that's a question for that's a
broadcast issue it's not us I'm Graham
Don I think there's a clueless gamer
there coming tonight or tomorrow we shot
it last week there we go
hello from Sweden hey Sweden hey India
what's up what's up what's up hey David
Taylor I'm good thank you Sharma for
asking alright so here's the thing man I
think we're just gonna go straight
sprint alright
I'm actually nervous I'm biting my nails
oh man does that mean he's closed when
the music gets crazy as I mean these
clothes go now go to the police all
right here we go ready
[Music]
oh no we broke all the windows we're the
cops dude we're the cops where do I go
[Music]
let's go man let's run let's get out of
here no Jesus
why is everyone running towards me
there he is dudes
he's walking real fast it's alright I'm
fine are the cops this way I'm in the
light where are the cops dude oh no I
ran toward the lake stop tripping you
idiot I'm just gonna die of fright oh
I'm dead he's got me he's so close
where are the stupid cops man
check the mini-map where's the mini-map
I lost it there's no map dudes oh it's
coming back here we go
where are the coppers
where are the cops dudes I hate this guy
you know I want this guy to die hate
this dude where the hell are the stupid
cops anybody
oh my god I'm just doing like laps in
this camp
I mean I'm sure the cops have to be
around here somewhere right the cops
leave do the cops into believing or they
here the whole time I need to know
anyone they don't have any idea they
left what do you mean they left the cops
leave in this game I thought the cops
are here the entire time no Jason is the
cop I'm running the wrong way what does
that mean oh I say she'd be running
where all the other guys are running
right it's dead by daylight fun you guys
they stay Jesus
can I get over this fence or what Jason
pretend to be a cop that's not true is
that true I climb over this thing how
does this work oh I'm so dead you guys
I'm so dead look at the red border on
the map oh I see
got it I'm so dead Jason is totally
gonna chase after me grab a map a real
weapon I'm screaming over here system
Jesus oh my god
defeated by defeated by a gate that's
true
better than getting hit with a car where
the hell are the cops men okay oh he's
coming for me oh it's coming hard Oh No
Oh brick free oh oh no this is gonna be
bad oh Jesus oh he Lara Croft me guys I
got Lara Croft 'add
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know what first of all if you're the
police drive into the camp you know what
I'm saying don't just wait outside the
camp come on in there's somebody running
around the Spear murdering people that I
couldn't eat throughout well then uh
yeah if you guys by the way have uh oh I
got squeezed ooh all right well I feel
like not bad because he killed most of
us um
police don't want a message Jason that's
two cops can be scared that's true
they're no dummies hey what's up marshal
Sara I don't know it now zfo be Jason
now let's see I'm ready man let's roll
uh yeah if you guys have this game add
me Blair BL e y AE ER t let's read the
top of the screen there that's my
gamertag I'm playing on ps4 today and
we'll play it will play a private match
it'll be really fun I want to play with
you guys you know let's do it maybe they
put stuff instead the gate is far enough
I mean look if I was a cop I totally be
scared oh great now I got a mute another
dude there we go I don't care what
people on the ED but what people in this
game have to say you know
obsidian egg TV yes I died horribly that
round BAM sup Boudreaux gaming you just
I need to set my counselor my Jason how
do I do that
I'll do it after this match it's stuck
at eight for some reason why is that
we're stuck at eight what's up
communication in this game is key to
survival I know Mike York but I just
feel like people are gonna yell out like
Hitler stuff now ah thank you you MUC
there's a corgi themed wow connection
timed out come on come on alright no
wait how do I set my Jason let's do that
few settings no progression customized
maybe how do I set which one do i how do
I do that I like this Jason this is my
favorite Jason I hate this other Jason
oh this guy's traps are like serious
look at those traps man this guy's great
this Jason is awesome of course
obviously Jason part seven is that the
Manhattan Jason you can see some little
you got a little uh got a little
something right here man and of course
the part nine the recent head Jason I
love that alright I don't know how to
spawn preference I guess there we go I
don't know I you know what because I say
let's just figure it out you don't have
Jason X part in 64 but I feel like traps
are deadly
'la missin no the really slow one was
the one with the spear I hate that one
the one who just killed me by the way oh
you know what maybe I set my weight
maybe I do that up here ah yes here we
go accept great and then let's ooh ooh
look at this now wait a second here oh I
think we only have one choice right
she's cool I'm gonna pick rocker girl
cuz they're stealth is 10 out of 10
let's be honest that's exactly what I
need just mute these fools Oh bear ski
well I'll bear ski look who just joined
bear ski let's do it
well well guys we got bear ski in the
chat in the game I like it pick a girl
one so we can see hot oh my god
hot buttocks running around uh-huh sure
yeah here we go
never hide if you're screwed if you
can't escape Touche
roleplay is goth girl moping a corner
it's a private event marshal Zahra Beth
is has to do other stuff today so I got
this little mask to keep me company
fire mixtape ooh baby ooh baby oh let's
do it Barry you got to tell me where to
go man you have to start winging out
till I get somebody killed I'm gonna
play golf throw that's true don't run
too much you need to keep your stamina
up all right fair enough enough ball
Preston get in here hey Matthew kill
Matthew Fernandez Tupac or biggie that's
a good question
I feel like biggie had uh had good flow
but I feel like Tupac maybe had better
overall songs is that crazy to say each
bout posh programers what five minutes I
think something like that I did put on
perks for Jason I just haven't unlocked
anything sadly waiting for some players
guys come on get in here yeah this is
great
again like I said before Comic Con last
year we had these we had VR headsets put
in here so it's kind of you could do VR
it's very heavy by the way and it
doesn't really balance in your head
though well it's like
it's pretty great really smells like
10,000 people's faces
that's a weird smell you don't think
about everyday oh god here we go guys
I'm nervous all right let's all do
together when the guy gets killed that's
all do with the sweater guy does ready I
love that all right here we go oh no
it's the Jason that can run oh I'm
nervous I got check here we go here we
go here we go let's go let's go all
right okay you know what I all right
she's already too talky what's happening
here
so talky let's look for some stuff to
defend ourself with like I'm ever gonna
get that far we don't lock this door to
just for good matter what's in here oh
we got a bat now we're talking baby got
bat nothing over here that's nervous
guys this music is not cool by the way
oh here we go I mean Jason Jason totally
gonna come after me right Tommy Jarvis
my boy Tommy I think we like the bat
better than that wrench right well we
like the poker better than all that [ __ ]
all right what do I do guys what do I do
yeah what's up cam em guys tell me what
to do do I stay in here okay I open the
window because I need to leave early
bathroom any med kits in here anything
I'll do pretty well so far rusty bucket
so I just hide or what kids
[Music]
to be heid what do we do what do you
guys do find a map of I haven't searched
everything I find stuff in the car play
the piano is he close get out and loot
explore I don't know man I like my
chances in here I should play to win
play to win the game well played he's
close do you think but he can't see me
if I'm in the closet right just kill him
what are you talking about just kill him
you're nuts
dead says razor he can hear my breath
not if he's only if he's close thank you
Eric Kennedy staying in here will help
me survive oh the music plays any time
anyone finds any counsel he finds a
counselor on the map no one could see me
in the closet he's in the closet with me
[Music]
we are playing Friday the 13th the game
it's very scary stream tonight oh hey
Mouse could you put the thing on the
left the yeah thanks dog well someone
got murdered that sounds like really bad
music that sounds like horrible music
I'm not gonna run Reese here I look we
called Tommy Jarvis Tommy's gonna take
care of things we're just gonna chill in
here here's the thing I like to think
like Jason
so Jason busts in here right he sees an
open window doesn't see anyone in here I
hold my breath you know nobody knows my
stress goes up the house in which I'm in
shines bright red pipe stress isn't up I
got chill I am guys so chill Oh God
Oh Oh the music's getting crazy they
better not lead it better not lead Jason
in here man yeah Hanson designs oh there
he is oh my god I see him oh no I see
you through the window don't come over
here dude we did call Tommy Jarvis Tommy
can kill him
well people are leaving and joining
what's happening got a little glitchy
glitch
all right should I go try to do the car
or what yeah the Friday 13th movies men
have 94 pretty yet all right I'm gonna
jump out right
I'm so nervous is such a bad idea what
if Jason's watching this dream I'm dead
slice your face all right let's do it by
the way I just for the record I just
want people to know that me leaving here
oh Jesus
oh boy I see him right there he's right
there dudes he's like running around the
house with that person how can I get out
of here the boat right the boat isn't
there a boat Antron what do you think
the boat what's the best course action
what do you do oh dude here he comes
oh I see him oh man that's really bad
all right you think this way oh my god I
hate this game I hate this game why
would I play this game I hate it this is
suicide better not lead them into this
house when you've really upset
oh Jesus give me out here let's go
[Music]
go back in the house what are you nuts
what do you mean he of course he's in
the house for the whole campus I know I
don't know dude he might have just I
think this is dumb this the dumbest
thing you've ever thought of Antoine so
stupid although now these things are
flashing my fear is just getting getting
bigger wherever he's chasey is coming in
this house by the way is that Circle him
oh my god dude flashlights on no way
Antoine secretly Jason yeah that'd be
hilarious
bTW I can't get out of this window oh no
running let's not run kids oh this is
such a mistake why am i back in this
house this is terrible this is terrible
is he the circle
oh god this music is the worst he's
chasing that person I see oh my god get
me out of this house I'll come back you
know only link
[Music]
oh good okay so now he's not close to me
right oh wait there's a gun right here
oh the guns good right can I pick up the
gun I think something's glitching in
this game a little bit I'm I can't
picking I see
I just crouch the whole time looking
dumbass all right here we go
guys got a flare gun oh no no he's after
me right there is there is there is when
that oh man I'm so nervous please turn
the flashlight no I hate flashlights
there is there he is I see him he can't
come through windows right guys
he's totally coming over here now he's
running away oh man I'm so nervous you
guys oh god I hate this game I hate this
game I hate this game so much go away go
away where's Tommy Jarvis man didn't I
call Tommy I come back as Tommy ah why
can't someone else come back as Tommy
I'm terrible at this game
burski what do you mean you're teaming
up with me I was running away you were
pulling Jason Weirich
oh now Jason's coming back oh no oh no
how do I be chasing you guys what do I
do
what do I do
[Music]
I'm not scared though right oh no here
he comes here he comes here he comes
here he comes
[Music]
I'm out of here by Jesus Christ don't
let's run away I'm so dead
what can I need to get out of here
anybody totally morphing over here right
now okay relax it was a good idea said
no one ever
this is dumb right what are we doing
laser - penguin games can't I wait him
out
I can't even [ __ ] I can't see anything
[Music]
guys so I leave the door wide open then
he he he's not gonna think I'm in here
right car police
[Music]
oh my god music is going bananas right
now holy Moses he sees what house I'm in
with the sense of God I don't know
enough about this game and when she's
laughing and nodding over there it's the
worst Oh God touch of red I'm not sure I
think Foucault's only be available i
comment counter by contest or
sweepstakes I'm not sure Oh
Trouty he must be here I don't see his
feet though can I just keep running what
do I do here hit the up-arrow to see if
someone is Tommy Jarvis neutered oh my
god
I'm alive who farted mixtape is alive oh
wait there's a lot of people were alive
oh so now he's not coming after me okay
he's not near me kids we're coming out
all right we're gonna get rid of our
fear by keeping this stupid light on so
we can see exactly where I am at all
times got the battery
so I want I want to go over by the car
right
oh man oh boy Oh was that Tommy
oh my god this is my scared face is
crazy in this game oh my look at that
face uh my flat my flashlight is dying
cool
[Music]
here he comes he's coming ah please man
where is he's close to me right all
right with somebody oh Jesus no he's in
here no no no Nana nanana nanana Nana
knew I went either the house that Jason
was in you dumbass what am i doing oh
god that was so stupid
the guy must have been like oh cool crap
[Music]
man
oh I'm getting killed where is he Oh can
I drop the battery or something oh wow
well done I guess like the okay you
don't need to you don't need to be a
jerk about it okay all right oh there's
only five minutes left I could have hid
oh my god oh my god yeah
who said Tim Coco I love it oh wait
we're spectating other players now I
love there's just there's the oh you
can't see it because it's blocking you
can't take this plug in to think that
there's a button that just says your
dead body you just want to see your dead
body you can always just go your dead
body
yeah and now I can hear myself through
barsky's thing that's right
I can hit Bursk I can hear myself
through you
oh man yes yes yes
Lygia penguin games I was using I don't
for her I don't know that I picked any
any perks which is dumb
should we try to do a private match with
everybody see this person is winning
this is what I should have done you guys
dumb is that true yeah oh you have to
escape yeah fair enough
oh it's YC so in 322 this interesting
let me take the boat I did find a way
that if you swim in the water Jason can
still like come up and grab you it was
awesome know diddly durin I don't that's
awesome
you could take you can kill Jason Matt
takes lad teamwork yeah Tomic toasty a
gooey 22 says anyone see this having a
long player base I think if they come
out with a story mode definitely they
come up with some DLCs more maps of
Jason X I mean I would love to see s on
reddit people are talking about this
game and somebody said they'd love to
see a Jason Takes Manhattan map I agree
with that'd be awesome Jason Takes
Manhattan be amazing
oh here we go now she's running
I'm gonna study her method a little bit
oh there's only one of only one person
left
well they got the Savini Jason as well
that's awesome yeah I agree cricket
Johnny it's great with friends I don't
have any friends oh don't go on the
water why not Jax it's a dead end
the movies are pretty good slice your
face the first ones great the first two
are fun
[Music]
[Music]
Oh dope all right great
oh that's awesome all right we can now
let's see if we can play with one of the
co-creators here so let's jump out let's
see how do we do this
ght yea emo kt9
oh wait I just want to see if she's
gonna make it I'll please make it I'm
nervous is Jason close to her by the way
this is cool when your spectating
someone else you can adjust the thing oh
she made it Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
it's skillet well played
I mean I died that's true I guess it
just wanted to remind me that I wasn't
playing her so thanks a lot
[Music]
[Laughter]
so great oh four out of six not too bad
not too bad all right let's see so we're
gonna try to let's see I'm going to send
a I'm gonna send an invite to everybody
let's see if we can do this actually
know what I think I might have to go out
go to my friends oh my let's see here
what's happening here let's do this
let's get all of our friend requests
accepted there's got to be by the way
playstation you got it you gotta help
help a brother out here there's got to
be easier way to do this than just
accepting all these dope people candy
just like accept all friends can't that
be a thing up I did it all
there we go I do it all man god I can't
keep up with these alright here we go so
now we're gonna go back to this we're
gonna do a private match see y'all
friends see if
so I think one of the co-creators of the
game is in the chat here let's see if we
can get him in I'll see him in here I
think it's yeah GC let's see here I
don't see him no hey ask ask Beth yeah I
don't see him in here I don't know I
have it here but I don't see that it's a
yeah Grinch but exactly I know let's see
what's you at Beth you do all right
let's uh let's get some folks let's play
let's play some games shall we do I just
hit the thing and it'll be all people
all my friends how should we do this all
right
a message from them let's see I mean I'm
gonna be I guess reading the message on
live stream I hope that's okay
notifications messages here we go here
we go maybe he's gonna invite me to
which to a thing but but but but but but
oh my god oh my god so many messages so
many messages
oh and wait the new one should be up top
right just now oh here it is
yeah
how do I invite this dude Oh what's
happening there are you doing
oh my controllers like oh thanks pal
look at this guy density to be perfect
did I Adam let's see have you all the
way down kids yeah yeah sorry perfect
alright now let's we're just gonna pick
some people here let's pick some folks
let's go up top that's taking you a
minute sorry I'll get bare skein here
because I felt bad for for screwing you
last time Barsky listen where's Barsky
hmm that's weird not showing up eh let's
go to the bottom Oh II monk monk once in
I feel like here's the thing one of the
co-creators we're gonna play with one of
the co-creators here and I feel like I
was getting killed before this is not
gonna help me you know like it's not
gonna be easier for me to go do this
alright alright here we go
alright let's go did that work no it did
you got to do it from here yeah dope all
right here we go Ronnie I'm Annette
it's gonna be great um so yeah if you
guys are just joining us we're playing
before I had a 13th game which is dope
but here's the thing it's horrifying so
uh you know like I don't know what to
say I mean you know if you're maybe you
want to put the lights on if that helps
you I don't know it doesn't help me the
music is really scary
I'm scared by Jason although I will say
beam Jason is not scary and it's super
fun there's nothing more fun I can't
select another player all right we'll
get you in next time bear ski do we
invite everybody how did that go did we
get everybody in there perfect no one's
in the lobby this worked out great I
hear people are just joining here we go
see it's happening Antoine ah
gab Zilla well maybe one day we'll talk
to one of these off it's just like
staring into Conan's real shark death
eyes exactly Oh Hobbs is in the chat so
Hobbs you're one of the co-creators of
this game congratulations I'm making an
amazing game this thing is super fun no
worries man this is great
[Music]
yeah should I you're all invited more
folks here
no I'm by myself just by myself
not everybody okay I didn't you guys are
select few and it's an egg no I did I'm
but I'm talking on the stream if you
guys are watching this stream I I don't
we have a mic here I'm ready baby
we're gonna we're gonna see how quickly
I die when we're actually playing with
somebody made the game so wait Hobbs I'm
guessing you're watching the stream
right because how else would you know
that we were doing this how was it - how
long did it take to make this game what
are some of the things you're most happy
about and that can you tease anything
you're gonna add in the future it'll be
yeah it'd be like it's like talking to
the person
[Music]
sadly all my friends are I think I have
some work I just done me making sense me
I don't know if you're actually paying
attention I have it I could invite as
many people as we want all right here we
go
Fisk everybody when you do this sounds
like whoever Jason is gonna stream snipe
the hell out of me that's true but you
know what dr. Julian alright thank you
thanks thanks a lot
thanks a lot thanks a lot thank you
thank you that's right we definitely
have a larger conan head than anywhere
else here so dude you be Jason I think
this TARDIS Lobby oh you don't want me
as Jason you don't want me is Jason
going how did you play Jason go for it
let's see how it's done let's see how
it's done hubs
that's keep it random random yeah yeah
let's do random with you guys feel
Hobbit of course Fiske don't die you're
gonna die I'm fine never bother me
ooh there we go all right here we go I'm
nervous so we're playing with with
Hobbes one of the co-creators of Friday
13th I'm very scared I was my scared
miss my level of fear was about an
eighth before and now it's around a
twelve on a scale of one to ten here we
go here we go we'll see ya that's our
goal yeah you know what it's not gonna
not gonna help anybody
don't don't don't die for me I'm not
worth it I'm not worthy
Oh Oh God
Oh No
[Music]
all right first of all don't talk to
yourself just be quiet
that's all I ask all right here we go
all right so what's the strategy here
somebody tell now that I'm playing with
the person made the game what should I
do here what's a good strategy walk us
through some stuff
unless of course Hobbes you're the
killer in which case oh I'm not gonna
run
I stinker some other people are here
[Music]
oh man
nervous what man with what my car using
Oh God
it's what I'm already dying and I was
already dying horribly now you've made
it worse by making a microphone alright
that's fine you know what it's I see
this as a challenge let's turn off my
light I hate flashlights and games it
makes me feel like I'm sitting duck I'm
just following Fabian right boot dude
look at this
oh your girl got an axe it's so good to
keep our light out I feel like Jason's
gonna see that easy Wow Oh God oh he
knows we're in here dude not cool not
cool
or did he cut power to the whole camp
okay you can do it by cavity right
is there a jetpack in this game just
curious where you can just like fly away
they should they should have that we
need the battery we need some gas oh god
oh god is he close dude what is the
music man oh my god come on bro
[Music]
all right I feel it better with Fabian
has the flare gun I feel wait way more
comfortable if you have our bliss do we
run away what do we do oh okay oh look
at this oh thanks baby
all right where we going man oh my god
don't let me die dude hold up the d-pad
to see the killers Oh snow's bros why
don't I invite snows bros of this snows
bro says once you remember who's whose
private match this is wouldn't want you
to get kicked out by accident if you
kill me so good to open all the windows
or you got to find the propeller to the
boat well you got the gas damn dude
let's go literally just following you
you know what I've never done is follow
someone else in this game and I'm gonna
do it I got your back dude he comes over
here I'm gonna hit him at the bow I
think he's real close right
alright so in this game you can only
escape by fixing the boat fixing the car
calling the police and having them come
or killing Jason which is like never
gonna happen I mean you can kill Jason
though just like in real life
ooh look at this wait I have a big
should I put this down somewhere the axe
is probably better for me right all
right so I'm looking I'm looking for a
gas or something I'm looking for the
battery uh the great Dylan you can swim
but you can't swim away and Jason can by
the way follow you in the water he does
his thing resync it he comes up and
grabs you saw I mean I did it when I was
Jason it was awesome if even he's just
taking it to the streets here alright so
[Music]
I'm already noticing Fabian has his
light on all the time take it
oh my god oh dude
[Music]
baby in what I would have a v-8 the
music is going crazy oh god I don't know
Oh David definitely got killed
oh my god oh no why do I feel like I'm
next dude
[Music]
[Music]
oh man what do I do now
alright we got to find the yeah Phoebe
you died I've just got to find the
battery guys we got to find the battery
we got to find the keys we're good we're
good we have a job we've a job to do and
we're gonna do it it's fine everything's
fine it's all good no Jason anywhere
right Jase is probably just a myth
anyway right guys probably just
something they tell us campers to scare
us right
probably not her not around or anything
right everybody okay
yeah Conan would die so quick in this
game or he was Jason died all so quick
he would die whether he's mob cheap
what's up hello
[Music]
uh-oh I think Jason saw me there is no
God no get away get away ya later sucker
in your face oh and your face dude run
girl
oh god please run run towards another
there we go let's go get in the car get
in the car get the card buddy get the
card get me get in the car please oh
there's boxes in the car who put boxes
in the car like it why they're BA come
on you guys are the worst oh man great
that's what happened last time
Oh see you later jerks
all right here we go you know what okay
well there's no reason to lock this to
our if I'm gonna do it I know I know it
doesn't matter but it makes you feel
better okay Soul Reaper makes me feel
better just take a quick minute and take
a quick little nap under the bed don't
worry about it why not
I'm exhausted it's all this oh Jesus
okay just let's not be a baby about this
[Music]
oh no not Jason's over here now the
door's locked
where are you where oh here okay all
right let's go oh man hey we're twins
we're like sisters or something I'm
telling you though dude chase chase
Jason's over on the left I'm just
warning he's behind us
we got adjacent incoming from the south
we got a bogey on our tail I will out
among sorry
is there another car somewhere are we
just carrying this battery for like
exercise oh my god
it's already / do you know where you're
going
thank goodness those boxes are safe
Doublemint twins yeah we are wearing
some really great booty shorts I will
say take the boat a professional what
battery hauler oh no dude this is bad
Jason's gonna be waiting for us this car
he knows what's up where's he at where's
he at
can we get in the car I think you did
too we're gonna keys what how many
things do we need for this dumb car can
we Hotwire it
oh she's got the keys all right how do I
get in the car the keys are in it dude
let's go the keys are in it right why
does it have
oh no we need the keys I see
oh dude he's close oh Jesus
oh god oh man oh this is real bad how
come you're running faster than me
anymore cardio Oh God
oh man this is really bad get the window
please get the window please I'm in here
stop yelling at me oh where are you
going
Oh God don't show the door shut the door
lock the door like I can't lock it I
can't lock it don't open the door please
- open the door he's right there your
yard let's go let's go hey maybe you
piano music let's go run away
would you please one would you please
run would you please run Oh God he's
right around the corner oh man he's
coming out I gotta go
he's going the other way I'm going this
way Oh God oh no oh no I'm going so slow
I'm going so slow I'm going so slow I'm
going so slow more cardio dude more
cardio
[Music]
just hang here for one second kids quick
PSA keep up on your car yo you never
know you never know what Jason's gonna
come at you you know what I'm saying
[Music]
all right well oh the cops are here all
right where do I go for the cops this
went horribly last time all right no
Jason feeling good about that all right
where do we think the cops are guys hey
guys here's that you forget to kid we
should disassemble the cars to hide the
parts all across camp yes seriously all
right so what do we think what do we
think we're the cops here
[Music]
yeah rule number one it's Ivy Lane dude
cardio always lets go
[Music]
maybe I could swim to the other side of
camp what do you guys think about that
that's a terrible idea right oh I'm
making so much noise in the water
oh god this was a bad idea I'm making
all the noise I'm making so much noise
[Music]
well this is what we call being bait for
other people all right well now I'm over
here just done nothing don't swim sorry
oh I see the cops I see the cops that
bridge right all right here we go
you might shoot to fill up let's just
turn this off for a second
with Jason's in the water he's basically
jaws cool well that's worth why Thank
You visca you know if you're gonna say
something nut oh I see somebody running
is that Jason said Jason that's what me
running all right let's go okay
don't go which way this way why why this
is the way I want to go okay I can get
out of the water right there can't I I'm
not going over there I'm going this way
[Music]
well I don't see Jason oh man yeah I'm
going to the barn bro so tired though
man
it's Jason close to us - tickets quick
nap do watch my back I'm gonna take a
quick 30-minute 20-minute nap you know
they say you should nap like around 20
minutes if you don't want to
[Music]
that baby I'm not allowed no mo Jeep do
have a baby with you cuz you should not
let a baby watch this game oh this is
really bad here he comes
let's go
where are the police in this game yeah
dude I'm trying to run man
a lot of ground missed over here so I
don't know where I'm going
he's right behind me I'm so dead I'm so
dead
hey buddy hey how are ya nope nope nope
nope nope nope I'm dead I'm dead oh
that's oh this is gonna be oh this is
gonna be a bad one oh Jesus oh damn it
speaking no wait a second speaking as
Jason why would you actually just kick
them back and then throw it you could
miss you know I see just you got him you
got in there just you know we're just
tickling just tickling to death boom
headshot oh oh oh oh goodness oh oh
that's yeah that's not fun oh that's Wow
Wow vicious vicious that was and there's
a baby in the chat I don't know what's
happening there's a freaking baby in the
jet what's going on oh my god horrifying
Hobbs you've made it truly a truly
disturbing game oh my god hey I can
level up though there we go oh my god
all right I think we have time for one
more match we're gonna play one more
round whoo I got the snake
what's the snake meat bookish girl
finally oh hello hello there all right I
think we're too late one more that's
exactly all right Hobbes I'm making you
the killer this time so show us how it's
done
okay you ready show us how it's done
that's all I ask
I mean look I'm hopeless I can't
yeah if you guys are just joining us for
playing what's that Jason yes the guys
all team up and try to kill Jason it's
gonna be great and by I'll team up I
mean you guys go after Jason and I'm
gonna get in that boat and see his
latest if you guys just joining us were
playing Friday the 13th the game it just
came out it's super fun it's basically
you and a bunch of people are counselors
and one of you is Jason and you hunt
down the other counselors in the
counselors try to escape it's really
really fun it's also going to give me
nightmares for the rest of my life and
if you're a fan of the movies it's
awesome it's got all different I think
there's seven different Jason's which is
insane and a whole different kind of
counseling a bunch of different
counselors Hobbes are there gonna be
there's gonna be DLC for this right I'm
guessing by the way oh really
Pamela's sweater whoo interesting oh you
have to get Pamela's sweater that's how
you
kill Jason Oh interesting
well now it comes out you know thanks
for telling me after I got killed on the
last round how convenient
I didn't know that information
beforehand also Hobbs if you're watching
you got to make a Manhattan I know it'd
be terrible but Jason Takes Manhattan
would be awesome just like maybe just
one apartment building or something and
be awesome alright here we go
alright all I want in this last match is
to not die a horrible death you know if
I just if I suicide by accident by
falling out of a window fine fine I just
don't want to get get glory killed if I
don't get glory killed I will consider
that a victory was it really perfect I
was like oh my god you're never you
didn't see me this right oh here we go
oh I love that guy
oh my god holy whoa what Jason is that
you're like out of fire oh my god I'm so
screwed all right
god I did do something I have to escape
yeah no [ __ ] okay
really you think we should escape let's
just run towards Jason all right here we
go all right it's ketchup gonna help
catch it's gonna help villain here we go
a wall all right here we go
both mob chief up coming in here we go
yeah what up all right here we go
go mean come into my house come into my
house that's all right now fuse your
dope although I shudder to think I'm
dying
oh well there we go there's a nap
oh yeah I'll tell you I could definitely
use that map if you got it oh yeah sis
they gonna show where the cops are
because I definitely need oh yeah I do I
got a machete oh man I'm never gonna
lose bring it Hobbes what do you got
bring it Hobbes okay person you can't
kill me I'm invincible I'm not
invincible at all I'm actually oh that's
another thing no problem all right
do you always keep the flashlight on or
no I guess not
[Music]
man I hate taking that barricade up but
I guess it's got to happen right
I'm doing a mob jeep des omni osis the
game is available now actually hide in
the bathtub that's what I do
ooh Tom Savini designed Jason Savini si
oh yeah Tom Savini is awesome no I would
not say it's a nice night for a walk I'd
say it's a terrible night there's a
killer on the loose this is the worst
night for a walk what are you talking
about lock three o'clock
yeah yeah got it keep my light off
thanks a Tinggi I'm gonna try but I get
scared very easily hiding the bathtub is
Jason not a tornado I feel like Jason
would just glory kill you by holding you
down turning on the water
hey waiting till I get this flare gun
flare guns are better right oh he's
close dudes he's close I'm nervous oh my
god is that us is he near us it's just
playing I don't know man
yeah it's working I'm horrified yes
Steve 9/4 is exactly working for Conan
feels like this is like us around the
office get away from the house why
here's the ready long oh yeah
EEMA I'll play on Sunday night for sure
wait how come everyone
oh woops sorry my bad she's gonna let
you have the house to yourself okay see
you know you want to I don't know take
some time
[Music]
they should be how exactly Gilbert here
we go so we're just chilling in here
this seems like the miss it you know
what some people found the dead guy from
the cutscene in the bathtub really
that's awesome also when this game
starts up we didn't show it but it's
awesome it's like all VHS it's really
cool like eighties man I'm nervous man
I'm nervous
Bob Jeep for their fan room it hashtag
just roommate things I say let's go
let's go try to escape man let's get out
of here
right Steve now at four I haven't really
had any issues getting into a match
sometimes like if I'm really really late
at night on the other there won't be a
lot of people around but for the most
part no just joins right up oh my god
mob don't make me muna dude I'm you in a
second
[Music]
I'm nervous man it's Hobbes just giving
us like a head start baby were you oh
God
[Music]
are there car keys somewhere yeah what
is happening oh my god
wait guys hey you have the same hairdo
as I do
should we all be in such close proximity
yeah I got it's very different people
handbag let's go all right here we go
Fabien where we going lead the way baby
just a couple of ladies on the prowl
Bobby are you freaking out what's going
on I think mom's having a seizure
corn is Jason could be interesting you
learn to controls I agree yes we are
darling we're walking towards a dead end
baby where's the car huh oh no this is
exactly what happens or horror movies
guys nobody knows where the car is all
right where we going cars
Oh dudes oh my god Hobbs already killed
two of us Oh No and he's like ghost
rider Jason or like fiery death balrog
Jason we know what oh man this there's
no way this is gonna end well for us
dudes also who leaves a campfire just
burning don't be a jerk you know only
you could stop forest fires right here
[Music]
I don't know man I'm nervous
Oh God Oh bear trap oh Jesus he's around
oh no oh God oh my god Jesus Bryce I
missed the fly run away holy crap oh man
oh man I'm so bloody this debt you've
definitely ruined my favorite dress
oh Jesus Christ why are we running back
to the car oh wait how do I get in the
car
[Music]
ah anything new Oh oh great oh great now
I got Jesus on my own oh man
oh that's vicious Timmy I was so close
oh oh you escaped you bastard
dude look at this Jason oh oh man oh man
oh my god dude oh we stuck I thought
what's here in the car that's it oh my
god he's pulling her out of the car oh
my god this is great this is like an
epic battle oh my god
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Oh God
Oh just a slow holy Moses
that was crazy that was just like three
kills in two seconds oh did he kill him
oh man
nope oh not Tom he's gonna try to get
away dude did you just see him pull
three people out in the car and murder
them horribly never never team up on the
developer never oh god oh lordy oh
that's just oh my god oh my god that was
a massacre this is awesome
Oh oh boy no way this is gonna go don't
get in the car do you have you beats
watching this you know it's been
happening oh Jesus
oh my god oh oh wow can't believe she
actually knocked it down but then watch
this the old sit-up it's my favorite
thing also I love the Evil Dead like
camera oh damn oh geez yeah this isn't
there's no way this is oh dude just just
give in [ __ ] you know what good who is
it Soul Reaper who's playing the girl
right now
oh there son there's somebody just in
the house
oh god I know I should have gotten in
his passenger side I thought I could get
in the back oh god oh boy nope oh this
job she got the one I got oh no she got
a new one oh god how many kills are
there in this game this is insane no
here we go we got one more left oh boy
No oh boy oh boy yeah this t-shirt
reminds me of my horse from Red Dead
Redemption that's true the warhorse I
love the look of this man by the way
that's not that's not flames that she's
bad body odor Jason really smells
terrible he just smells awful I mean
look so would you if you had you're just
wearing whether in the heat summer camp
you know all that like leather pants oh
god oh god
yep there it is oh she kicked away kick
out Oh get him she's too afraid she's
too afraid oh my god
horrifying there are a lot of kill says
she's greater oh boy just doesn't oh my
god
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean I gotta say that's a great
sweater but I also want to see it just
get completely impaled by a crazy
Trident Oh God
I'll let me just break through the
Diller Oh almost you almost did Wow
well look when you play against a
developer they're gonna put on a clinic
daddy that is how it's done that is how
it's done my god good lord well Hoffs
congratulations you made a hell of a
game guys the game thank you for playing
the game is Friday the 13th the game
it's available now super super fun this
game is horrifying don't feel bad for
for killing us all an absolute mess and
thank you all for tuning in we will see
you all right back here next week for
another extreme cocoa see you guys later
[Music]
you